all right hello everyone we are
continuing our version 14 design reviews
and Ricardo is about to present some
things to do with external
evaluation please go ahead yes so um
okay so today we're going to talk about
changes we are introducing in external
evaluate and later to some addition we
have done to the testing framework um
mostly the external evaluate is just um
a review we already seen internally most
of this stuff so I expect this to be
relatively smoothly uh on the other hand
we need to talk a little bit more um on
the testing stuff because we have more
issues to resolve
there okay um so for 14 we are
introducing the ability uh in external
evaluate to basically provision and
create environments on demand um the
syntax is what you see here basically
there is a specification that you can
put where previously you were putting
only the python executable um and this
specification allows you to basically is
the word python shouldn't it be
capitalized in that in that sentence
creating python
environment um
I mean this is part no no no no no no no
no no no no in the in the progress
monitor oh yes I see yeah okay so I mean
we're supposed to have a procedure now
for reviewing progress monitors I don't
that only just got launched but this
should go through
that sure well consider that everything
that is coming out from the progress
monitor is coming straight from STD out
but yes I control the idle and where
possible we can do the fixes okay all
right so as you have seen basically has
been what 30 40
seconds uh the process is done and so
this guy installed the environment under
this um I don't understand why register
external evaluator doesn't come back
with some kind of object while it comes
back with a naked uh
path doesn't what does external isn't an
external evaluator a blob represented by
a summary
box uh that is only the running session
we currently don't have no the the
external evaluate Target is always going
to be historically it's been always a
part to a file um but when you do
register evaluator usually what does it
return okay yeah this is something that
we would like to change basically it
will return the U
ID until now it Returns the U ID of the
evaluator that you have it's never
returned we don't never had an external
evaluator object
before
but that's what we want now because I
mean returning a u ID can you show me
just show me the documentation page show
me what it actually normally
returns
just about wait here you
go and so normally when you um it
Returns the key in the registry uh that
is associated yeah basically the key
that it creates inside the registry okay
this is wrong what it's doing now I mean
this is not consistent what it was doing
before is kind of a
hack right
returning look what it should be
doing is returning something presumably
I can say external evaluate and then one
of those uu IDs and then it will
external evaluate against that
registered external evaluator
correct we are adding disability now so
previously disability wasn't even there
um so the the register external
evaluator is returning a uid but you
cannot really start a session by
referring to the uuid how do you have to
start the session how do you how do you
refer to that U ID okay you go to
this so we are adding now a third
argument in external evaluate which is
basically it allows you to do to give it
a name and now you can do something like
Python and name goes to and you use the
uh basically the ID that you that you
the name that you specified so now
basically we are adding the ability to
I'm totally confused would you go back
again go back again MH okay so you said
I mean I don't know understand why this
isn't sort of an abuse of register
external
evaluator this is essentially creating a
what would you normally do with register
external evaluator what would you
normally what would its arguments
normally
be the first argument is the system the
second argument is is the file on disk
uh that basically is the python uh
executable or any other okay so you're
replacing that by the Association that
gives the
dependencies exactly so that dependency
now uh get processed by register
external evaluator and it returns to you
the evaluator that was just created in
this case I guess I guess it's lovely
but now the thing it's returning is so
totally different from just returning a
uu ID right these is the changes we I
don't think it's right I'm sorry I just
don't think it's right one thing about
regist value though it's it's never it's
just a side effect thing right I I don't
think anyone has ever used the return
value from register external value you
you mostly use it done it's it's got a
uu ID how do they how do they refer to
that
installation well that's that's the
thing I mean until now you don't have
really a way to start from external
evaluate uid um okay how do you pick
which of the seven pythons that is
rising around in your computer you're
going to
use um yeah so a prev previously there
were a verion that allows you to this is
all stuff we are trying to solve
basically um and and we are redesigning
the also the return value of register
external evaluator so that you can
directly use it um and I think I think
rard though I think I agree I'm having a
hard time understanding the change
without understanding how it was
intended to be used before like why the
change is
necessary yeah and and so the thing is
that before it was rning the ID of the
evaluator but you don't really have a
way to use this ID inste an external
evaluate call so I'm not really sure
either how people were were were doing
it before um one thing register has
always been basically a side effect type
function one thing it does is it if you
say register python blah it makes that
python the the preferred evaluator for
python if you just call if you just say
external evaluate python comma 2 plus2
right the question is how does that pick
the python to use well it picks the most
recently re registered evaluator for
python um you know that's always been
kind of ugly but that's that's it's
always been basically a side effect
function where the return value is not
of any use you you register some things
to set your system up and then you can
either you know use the python use the
evaluators by path or you just rely on
the default Behavior register external
valuat makes this evaluator the default
for that
language makes everything much much
easier right I that's a good idea from
Ricard I'm sorry could you say that
again naming the environments which is
what Ricardo is proposing is a really
good idea I mean that makes everything
so much easier yeah right so now we have
the ability to assign a friend L name
and that's that's the side effect right
you you assign a friendly name to this
evaluator you can either use the full
path to the evaluat is another argument
to register external evaluator or you
can and that's the return value if you
want to use the return value it's now
useful but you can also I think you
should be able whatever happens in my
opinion you should be able to use the
return value from register external
evaluator in external evaluate if it's a
random uu ID that refers to Ruby or
something then so let it
be right I mean in our system the more
common thing would be that it's an
object represented by a summary box and
you pick that up and you use it rather
than a naked uh uu
ID we could right we could have in the
past or now invented a new thing
external evaluator know object sort of
thing that
you know a new symbol in the system that
would have a summary box but it's
just the thing is that people don't
program with calling register people
don't call register external evaluator
very often it's not part of your it's
typically not part of your programming
where you you have that in in your
notebook and you call it every time you
it's you just call external evaluate
python blah and if if if you want to set
up which python that is well then you at
some point in your life you call
register this this thing is it going to
be persistent given a name assigned to a
python with certain dependencies what's
the level of persistence it's
persistent it's definitely persistent
you would not call registrational
evaluator typically in your session you
do it it's the sort of thing you do once
and then from then on you you don't you
don't use you don't called regist
directional evaluator
again that's why the return value is
necessarily all that
useful I mean the the also the main idea
is that you know there are a variety of
specification that can go into the
second argument so typically yes it's a
file or it's a string in case of a
database it's a database reference
object you pass it in but it could be a
URL it can be also string uh the guy
normalizes to the to to to what it's
approach for every evaluator so for
example for SQL it's a database
reference object and even if you put in
a string or an URL Etc it gives you back
database reference so in this case the
the normal form of the evaluator is a
string
um and so the typical return value here
it's a string because this is what we
historically use in order to refer to um
basically evaluator on
disk I'm sorry show show how you can use
the return value right now from extern
register external valuate if you want
right um so I just want to be clear once
you've got a return value from register
external evaluator whatever it is it
should be a thing that you can
persistently use inside external
evaluate on that same
machine yes so this is what I'm doing
here so basically you register the
evaluator I got it and then then it
returns that L string exactly and this
is the path to the evaluator and then
you can use it directly right I don't
understand why evaluator goes like that
I no no the return value from register
external evaluate to should be something
that you can pass nakedly as the first
argument of external evaluate not with
some kind of weird rapper where you're
telling it again that it's a python
instance you see what I'm
saying U we have to we'd have to either
have it return well a uu ID which and
then and then have some sort of you know
reverse look up with The UU ID or we
would have an ex external evaluator
object or something which I think is the
better idea well hold on I mean is that
really I mean if clearly in individually
registered evaluators are associated
with a name but they they should still
be distinct right like I'm if I it's
kind of my fault if I register a python
evaluator with what you know called Foo
and then later register a Julia
evaluator called Foo right I mean that's
it's one namespace of named evaluators
and it's my fault if I have a collision
from different languages um so in that
in that sense it is redundant to have to
respecify the language assuming we can
count on people to not make duplicate
where are you giving the name and
register external evaluator where do you
give the name so it's a third argument
um and basically yeah you can
there you go but but but right now that
name doesn't stand alone as a it's it
needs to it needs to it needs to you
need to be able to just give
that okay which is really
straightforward I mean well it's not
necessar it's sort of but but right now
you know start external session you can
just say the string python right so we
have if you do that then you have to
give that as a second look if you do
that
you can either use Ricardo EnV or you
can use list python comma Ricardo en or
you can use a uu ID all three of those
about just python but python that's fine
but then there's a default which is I
don't know how it determines the default
right but what's the one string if you
just give a string as the first argument
to to start external session or external
value no I I don't know how it
determines which of the seven writhing
pythons ends up sticking
that's not so much the issue the issue
is just that if you're saying that this
name could also be used as just the
naked first argument to external value
yep then it it sort of lands in the same
name space as all the names of languages
on your exactly right so if you're
stupid enough to name that python you
will get
confused right just like if you reset
plus you will get
confused well okay so basically I mean
but what if you say what if you say but
what if you use a language that
you you you don't have what if you say
hasco or something right and you don't
have we want to be able to to to say oh
we don't see hasal let's look for a
packet that says it has external value
for hasal right right now that argument
as a string is treated in a special way
look here's the deal
just like we do elsewhere in the system
if you defined it as a userdefined thing
then and and you've got a definition for
it then boom you use the userdefined
definition if you don't have a
userdefined definition it goes and tries
to use a system one or if necessary
looks for a packet that does
that am I making sense yeah that is
consistent we could just say right you
say hasle there and don't have a thing
called hascal then we do the the lookup
uh that I was talking about yeah then we
do the
lookup this seems reasonable but I just
think whatever you return from register
external evaluator you've got to be able
to use that now okay then then then we
need to rever this change where
basically register external evary
returns either the uuid that is created
or the name and so the we we keep the
register external evalu return value to
be the name or the U no I don't think
you need to do that you can have it be
that path if you want you just have to
have a hash table that has that path in
it just like you have a hash table that
has The UU ID in
[Music]
it not really I mean this is risky
because now this thing is a is a string
that RS to the python thing and and I
will need to I mean why Pyon not no JS
or not no no no listen to what I'm
saying you've got a uu ID The UU ID you
know goes into the table of external
evaluators right and it knows everything
based on having hit that element of the
table of external evaluators right think
of this string as another key another
hash code basically for but you could
have multiple you could have multiple
registered external valuators for python
that use the same path I don't know why
you would but you could right this path
is necessarily unique looking up in that
not only that but also there are
expressions that can be complicated I
mean I the the the database reference uh
contains all kinds of expression I mean
ashing it and and yeah I see it's I
don't think I think the correct place to
go which we probably can't get to for
this version is an external evaluator
object okay then I think we need to
delay this change just to be on the safe
side basically we we we have registered
external evaluator to return the the the
name of the uid so that we don't make
breaking change for nothing fine um and
then we and then we fine but then the
thing you're adding is the name for the
external
evaluator that's a fine thing and then
then when you call the thing then then
you will put it under name here so
basically you you right now in in the
current implementation and everything
you this thing will return Ricardo M and
then you can put the return value into
this key name why do you need that
explicit name why going to just read
Python and then that
list uh we we we can try to implement
that yeah what you suggest next question
I'm I'm just suggesting you you should
just say list python comma Ricardo end I
mean is there a good reason not to do
that well if we if we are GNA move
towards an external evaluator object
then we don't even need the python right
it would just be correct all right leave
leave the name for now okay but here's
the question in a wfr needs a
complicated environment what does it
actually look
like okay um well in a more complicated
environment basically I'm not talking
about more complicated even this
complicated I just want to know what
does somebody put when they write the
wfr so basically when they write a wfr
they will write just this external
evaluate um and then you do BU Pyon and
then goes to let me go all this stuff
and then you do 2+
two uh sorry doesn't make sense
to oh what are you doing put the quotes
I have no
idea um but it's not
working it's not you're not allowed to
say base directory anything I don't want
you to see anything with the python
runtime nothing like that is there
nothing like that is there this is a to
be distributed to different people's
systems sure sure no exactly so so in in
the base directory you're not going to
change it and you're probably not going
to to use this this specification you're
going to put something like
311 uh or 3.10 here you're are going to
AR code all your dependency and pin them
to the right
version um and so basically this is done
by we we are going to do a workflow for
that because in the end you need to do
pip install um all your packages then
you need to run wait a minute we're
doing that right because this is this is
listen listen the whole point here which
if we don't achieve this we might as
well just hang up hang up this effort
and go home type thing is that people
are supposed to be able to write a wfr
that makes use of uh a python package
and it is fully encapsulated they don't
have to know the user of the wfr
we got that Stephen we got that when
Ricardo said the author of The wfr has
to perform this step of getting the
dependency strings correct and that
that's the author of The wfr but who's
pipping anything I mean author of The
yeah so so the only issue is that you
you can write this Stephen you can write
this or you can write only only this
only this thing the problem is that with
time software changes and and this thing
will bring down dependency that so
basically the right thing to do is to
freeze all your dependency and I got it
and there's a way to do that using some
kind of pip command exactly exactly I
mean if
you're most of the time you why don't we
provide a wfr that runs pip and that
gets you that dependency
string yes in into the workflow or yeah
so why don't we provide a wfr that's
called you know find python dependencies
or something or find python dependency
string something like that sure
generates that string or generates that
dependency list right from whatever it
is that you would give you know give me
the current versions of all these things
so that I can freeze it you know even
though the pythons will continue to ride
around
right yeah I suppose that's feasible to
write a wfr to do that right yeah think
so no but that's very nice so what
you're describing here is the more is
the less
encapsulated
uh version of that where somebody is
just sort of putting it on their
system for permanence on their system
rather than having it be part of a more
ephemeral wfr type thing yes so
basically what you do is that you define
some
variable uh that would go
far why are we defining a variable what
def they don't need to they don't need
to no so they shouldn't yeah put in
there what what I'm saying yeah they
they need to save this Association
somewhere uh or they can put it save it
permanently because the wfr is a fully
encapsulated object right wait hold
second car's talkinging about the author
of The WF this is what the wfr author
puts in their vote he's not talking
about users of the dev yeah okay that's
fine they don't do anything but they
don't get to have a persistent variable
they get to have a function sure sure
sure right they run the function and
internally the function will always call
this Association which takes care of
basically updating the system if if
needed or just use the existing system
if if everything was already
installed
so yeah I mean I think we if there is
nothing more here I would like to uh
basically move on because what's the
neat
example well the neat example was just a
a syntax that is built on python um and
so you see the first time I run it um
it's going to create the environment so
you see that when the when python is
already downloaded it takes four or five
second to to build an environment it
obviously depends from how many
dependency you
got um and basically this this this
example is using a syntax letter to uh
yeah do syntax letter I like it very
much this is great I mean this is a this
is a good example
yeah
yeah and um
for yeah I should
say uh yeah this is what they use inside
yeah imp pment well why don't we get it
fixed yeah let's get it fixed
please indeed and there should be
Alternatives but let's get it fixed I've
said that actually three times before I
believe
how about we actually do it this right
so Aubrey make make sure that I know
someone did something with this yeah
let's make sure it actually after you
talked about the last
time all right next item right okay uh
so let's move to the testing framework
um so in the last version we created uh
we we added to the system a function
that is called test create uh that
allows you to to basically you know um
we we we we divided the evaluation step
from the creation step so yeah the
addition we're doing this time is uh is
different we we allow you basically to
have what we call checkpoints and we are
not really sure about this name but uh
tentatively is this one uh inside a test
when did we introduce test gr was that
in 133 133 okay yeah um and so the
overall idea is that by if you just run
test checkpoint it doesn't do anything
special it Returns the evaluation of the
first argument but in the meantime is
emitting a message to the testing
framework um good idea more like Ren so
basically the the test collects all the
event and they are stored inside
the um inside the object I don't think
it should be called checkpoint shouldn't
it be called test logging or something
um we can get
there have discussion about the names
which we'll get to um yeah just a quick
real world example of how this will be
used so supposedly you want to um export
a string into your disk and then read it
back and make sure that you know
everything all the uni character there
then you want to delete the file etc etc
so you see that now at every step you
can record um and freeze what the values
were um um and that allows you to
quickly debug and see
um yeah wait what what are the arguments
to test checkpoint here one of them is
an expert that you're just evaluating
yeah is the same order of uh the
arguments of test create so the first
argument is the expression you want to
evaluate the second argument is the
matching um the expected output and then
you can have same test in order to
customize you see that the second
argument should
beit AE conditions under which test
checkpoint issues a checkpoint or I mean
if I just want to always put in my
testing thing I reach this point what do
I
do you understand what I'm saying I I
always want to put in that test object I
want to declare that it reached this
point I'm here how do I do
that I believe that's just what the
default behavior of test checkpoint is
because checkpoint test checkpoint it
never Alters control flow it always
records you know this condition
was sucessful argument
then whether it records it or not no no
it's second AR it's it's exactly the
same argument structure as verification
test it's the the computed value and the
expected value in this case it's like a
subtest it's like a test within a test
what does it do so I want to know how do
I get it to alwayss it always does you
don't to do anything that's just what it
does that's just by definition that's
what it does even that second thing
fails even if the second the the underst
store string question mark file exists
you independent of that value what does
it do it will continue to
run doesn't to run what does it put in
the test output it adds an item to that
table below where the failure type is
something that describes you know your
value didn't match that test or it did
as the case may be or it did yeah but
either just wanted to throw a thing that
says I reached
here
into uh that that will be something
different um we we we we we we are
considering exploring yeah some
something that breaks also control flow
or um but but this is not what this
function
does but I'm not sure I understand what
you
want in terms of this I mean it also
suggests that the name test checkpoint
is confusing because it's
not it's not like just it's like a
subtest within a test I don't know what
you mean by wanting why is the subtest I
don't understand the thing is just
running through and this is not
affecting the control flow but throwing
other data into the test result logs
that's it might yeah I mean it might be
helpful to understand the motivation so
the place this came from is that we're
trying to make it easier for people to
encapsulate uh what are currently
written multiple separate tests into a
single test that's testing multiple
properties at the same time so the idea
is that and the example we we started
with is uh you know Todd has tests
testing the packet manager and there are
certain tests where it's one logical
test that's testing five different
fields in an association right like
there are five fields in the packet
object Association that he wants that
test to validate all have the expected
value if he were to write that test you
know as some kind of a single
verification test where the expected
value was an association and you know
the the the computed value was an
association and only one field from that
Association didn't match it would be
difficult to deduce what the problem was
test checkpoint is intended to allow him
to rewrite what are currently five tests
as one one test with five test
checkpoints so then he can see
individually okay four of the
association values say are correct but
one is incorrect but even though one of
them might fail he doesn't want the test
to stop running it should still test all
the other properties as well so that's
that's the motivation behind test
checkpoint yeah also there is also the
motivation that is one and there is also
this this kind of motivation where you
have a procedural program with several
things that needs to be done in a
certain order and you want to make sure
that at every step they are done um the
the evaluation keeps going here because
we feel that if you want to stop the the
evaluation uh you can simply throw or
break control flow with other uh W from
language
construct um and so we feel that
basically the St checkpoint should
should keep the test going in order to
regard uh all possible information as
much as
possible um Let me let me just try and
start this meeting a bit because I'm
going to run out of time at the top of
the hour um just give me a sense of what
else we have to figure out
here um no not much uh we need to figure
out the name and we need to review a
couple of properties that are coming out
from the that are a consequence of this
name so basically there is a property
that allows you to extract checkpoints
from um um uh from the test you see that
this is the inner test and you can ask
for the first level of the checkpoint
that is inside which is just one because
there is only one checkpoint here but
there are actually two because another
one is nested and so there is another
property that allows you to
extract uh
recursively uh all the this checkpoint
uh you see that internally the
checkpoints are just another test
object uh like the other
one um and yeah more or less I guess
with the time that we have we should try
to figure out what the name of test
checkpoint should
be all right tell me
again test
checkpoint test create let's go back to
test create sure what's the difference
between test checkpoint and text test
create uh well the test checkpoint it's
only emitting an event um and yes it's
performing a test but it returns to you
the the actual value of the
evaluation uh test create creates the
test and inside test create you're gonna
have those sub test no I I understand
what does test create do test create
creates a test object of some kind right
yes yes it creates a test object that
has not been evaluated yet then you
evaluate it it and um and yeah you got
an outcome
back okay but at runtime so this is the
runtime analog so if I just if I
put okay let's say I say test evaluate
and then in there I have a test
checkpoint test evaluate returns a test
object true statement or not true
statement
uh test evaluate yes on test object okay
show it to me test evaluate of 2 plus
two show me what it does no no no no
test no no no it doesn't doesn't work
this way no if you do test value at 2
plus two it doesn't just show me what it
does I'm actually not sure what it yeah
because it needs to take either a test
object or an
association uh so you you you need to
already construct the the the the test
by using test create then you pass it to
test why is it the case that you know
you could want pure runtime
testing that is that would be
verification test that is verification
test and it's what we already had like
since 10 years and yes it's working
fine people use it all the time but the
problem is that okay show me test
checkpoint okay test checkpoint is
another runtime test right it doesn't
sit there symbolically it actually
evaluates right correct this is super
confusing just like verification test
actually evaluates right so you're
bringing in another example having
having said verification test is wrong
because it actually evaluates you're now
coming back and saying well actually we
need something which actually evaluates
Am I
Wrong it doesn't test test checkpoint is
typically inside a test object which
doesn't that but just answer my question
test checkpoint like verification test
actually
evaluates after the whole production
about how important it was to have a
test object that doesn't evaluate right
but test checkpoint isn't a standalone
thing it you put it inside a test object
it does evaluate outside a test object
if you just but but that's not it's it's
it's not a standalone function it it
lives inside a test
object yes as a thing it's kind of like
echo in the sense that it evaluates and
it has a side effect right whether this
worked or not and then goes on I think
the confusion is that uh I think stepen
you think that test checkpoint does
evaluate eagerly even inside test object
and that I think is not true it
evaluates eagerly only if it's standing
outside but if it's inside then it's
only evaluated when test evaluate is
applied to the unevaluated test object
but not before no I I get that I realize
that because test object holds
everything exactly how could it possibly
have valuate
anything right right it's okay so so
test checkpoint I don't understand why
it isn't just Why does it have yet
another test in
it you're saying
that I'm just completely confused and
your example with I don't understand it
you say AO equals blah and then you run
test checkpoint on the various keys of
the asso is that right
but I understand that I mean you're not
returning anything there it's if it's
like Echo it's trying to return
something well this example this is
basically what or less like a multistep
thing where where where you export and
you check that a file exists then you
check that the return value is a certain
thing then you delete the file etc etc
etc um
so otherwise basically start to
understand what what was the thing that
was going wrong exactly uh might have
been that the file was not there and
then you need to figure it out by a
message or anything else so basically it
allows you to then structure a a big
test into into into several step well I
think it's I mean maybe one thing that
Stephen's getting at here is that like
the fact that it's it's ex evaluating
immediately right means that in theory
if that test checkpoint certainly the
second one which is just a statement if
that was just verification test in many
ways that's not super distinguishable
from what test checkpoint is doing
because it's just you know it's not
using a return value it's just executing
that test immediately it's really the
fact that the first test checkpoint
returns something that makes it
different and you could make the
argument that instead of having test
checkpoint where the return value is
Meaningful you could rewrite this this
code AS export path equals just that
export statement and then inside the
body of the width you have a test
checkpoint comparing export path to that
condition so the fact that we've merged
those together into one is yeah it's
like Echo is convenient but you could
use Echo as a pure side effect or you
can use Echo with its return value yeah
yeah right which you can do a test same
thing with test I mean it's a okay hold
on hold on hold on hold
on in fact the it's it's a p side
effect I I know I realized that
okay
although I don't understand why I need a
test there I mean in other words I just
want to throw something that says in my
testing results and I don't know if if
arod is here but he would certainly have
an opinion yes he is I mean I would
assume that it's very useful in testing
to be able to say the code reached this
point no test just the code got here I
made it here am I making
sense yeah I mean many people do that
with just a print statement I understand
that but this is now doing that with
test objects you can test the code made
it to this
point and and and I think that is in
effect what test checkpoint is doing
it's it's you know you end up with a log
in the resulting outer test of which
checkpoints were
reached yes I you could use it for that
purpose is just to do nothing more than
just have some sort of phony test in
there that
just pass to indicate that you got here
yeah well I think you need that I mean
you need that
case well you can do that right now you
just say test checkpoint of I don't
know one comma one or something and then
in your results for the test you'll see
that checkpoint there as passing you can
see I have a
feeling
but that's not what it's for it's
for testing Parts like I think of it as
subtest I think the name test checkpoint
yeah I mean the the the the reason
basically why we are doing this design
is because you know we wanted to have a
to have a test
group um but basically we realized that
it was difficult with the existing
framework that we have to have test
group and it would have been a better
Feit to have sub test inside test so
basically so look I got a suggestion
you've really got two things going on
here the pure I made it here just put
something into the test
output you know the idea of a hacky
thing where you type one one is just
ridiculous if I might say so that's
ridiculous but I don't why would you I'm
not sure why you would but for the
reason I just explained to be able to
put into your testing the fact that you
reached this point in the code but
that another way yeah right I if we had
a way to capture during test running you
know just like block of dollar output
kind of thing to capture
events you know that something was
printed something was echoed that might
be just as useful and arguably I mean
you know more useful would be useful
that is a separate thing we could have
some like test
event you know that would fire some
event that would be recorded perhaps
you know test event yeah or test log
maybe just test log right how does all
of this relate how does all of this
relate to the assert function that we
already have because I mean that's kind
of like what you want to do when you
want to see things but that's an assert
which test makes a test I'm saying you
just want to say I made it here okay
what you're doing there is you're saying
you know evaluate an expression test its
value
okay um and then record the result of
testing its value which God knows why I
mean I don't know the it's
really and and then in the Manifest of
how many tests succeeded and how many
failed if there are a bunch of failed
test checkpoint tests I assume that
those are counted against test success
no no no they they're not why
let him finish Dem it's it's right
because it's not possible to do that um
but the point is that the outer hold I
think you you guys just talk in order to
not the outer test fail Stephen if any
of the test checkpoints fail the outer
test is listed as a failure so that's
what counts in the set of you know I
have 37 tests and five failed we we we
don't lose the fact that a test
checkpoint
failed right but but the other tests the
other checkpoints the test continues to
run past the checkpoint and you know
also this this functionality that you
are proposing Stephen where basically
there is some kind of breakpoint in your
code I think this is a generic
functionality is not related to the
testing system you should be able to put
a breakpoint here and it should work I
don't think he wants a breakpoint I
think wants a test yeah a way to record
something in the test
results that is other because right now
the only test result we have is whether
the thing fail or not and now we have
these test checkpoints listed as with
their results but if you have some test
log that would also record just record
all the STD out that is that is coming
out no I want to record the specific
message that I put in to say it got to
this point record that I don't want
standard out that's a different what
what I'm saying is Echo we could record
the echo itself inside that's fine but
that's a different thing that's not what
I'm talking about here I don't want Echo
I don't want you know random crud
printed on my screen I just want to
record in the testing system that it got
to this place in the
code so what what if the way we modeled
this is that there's every test has
essentially like an execution log and
there's three types of events at least
so far maybe we'll add more there's test
check points there's test logs and then
there's kind of lower priority anything
else that was printed you know whether
it's from print or echo or message or
assert that would be useful and then you
could even filter I mean there could be
filters like hide the low value Prints
but only show me the logs or only show
me the checkpoints or whatever you want
to see yeah yeah g because print output
is actually you know might be useful to
sure capure and program against and the
sequence of when these things arose is
important that contains
information
yeah okay let's go down to the name of
test
checkpoint I mean I don't like this test
log thing the fact is that you know we
need a logging framework in general
that's
not yeah well that's for sure
um I mean that's something we've talked
about in the eror handling group about I
mean I think the you know we've had idea
about function like advise or emit
something along those names that's
structured log log message or something
and then put a wrapper around it that
says logging with
logging why not why don't have a
function called with logging and then uh
post to log or something or some some
other um
or uh
I mean unfortunately log as a logarithm
is a um we could just say
[Music]
um we just need a term you know with
logging would be something
where like absolute timing or something
it would return the log messages as well
as the value of the executed piece of of
uh of code mhm see what I'm saying yeah
and then it would it would have a thing
that says
um you know it could be emit log
although that sounds a bit weird but
something like that emit log and then
you just put whatever the heck you want
in there and then you can you know lace
your code with those
things
um or it's a version of
echo
uh well I'm sure we have echol log that
would definitely be a function we add in
that
hypothetical right which both Echoes and
throws it in the log yeah and returns it
right yeah and then quiet so you could
say with logging of quiet of
blah which will be a way of Bank
switching all your
Echoes you see what I'm
saying I don't I don't quite follow why
why quiet is related to Echo what what
do we do we have a quiet Echo function
right oh oh I'm quiet Echo yeah okay I
said the wrong thing yeah
yeah um but but tell let's the logging
framework is great but let's talk let's
try to get a name for this let's try to
get the name yeah all right but please
remember those two names okay yeah with
logging I like that um
so it isn't test so because it's not an
un an
unfettered so I mean that would be a
reasonable thing to
do by the way I really have to leave but
but that would be a reasonable thing to
do if it was if it was just throwing a
message in
there see what I'm saying
yeah this is both testing
[Music]
and I think it's easy to think of it as
like a a
subtest I do I kind of like test
checkpoint but maybe that name is well I
mean suggests things that it doesn't do
or isn't intended for I think a
checkpoint people stop at a
checkpoint like Charlie or something and
then they keep going
hopefully yes but this doesn't ever stop
nobody ever get stop but it does record
something yeah which is not what a
checkpoint is a checkpoint is you know
your papers are not in order you got to
go go somewhere different right that
never happens here that's not what this
is well depends I
mean control flow is not you know the
control flow the people just walk
straight through but but but but the
actual result of the test is is
influenced because if the checkpoint
fails the other test
fails it's not the right thing to call
it so in some sense you're either going
versus success or vers or toward failure
I don't think it's
thing sure sure this is why we're here
yeah okay mean so just the ones we liked
I mean subtest with
test yeah the one that we like the most
though it has other issues is tested
it's actually the very last one on this
list oh God no the part of speech this
is not no way um I mean let's go back
again to what this is okay so what is
this this is within a created
test this is a see it's not a subtest
because it's it is a test of a different
kind it is a runtime
test as opposed to a test object
I think if you call it subsidiary test
or subtest it's really
obscure
um that's not a test
case there are some other suggestions
here just if you want to take a look
none of them yeah okay all right
but what about something like test
point which doesn't have this checkpoint
which bothers
me because I don't mind that but but
then I like test checkpoint so I don't
mind test point It's seems like I don't
know seems deliberate of
checkpoint what what is the sentence
that you say how do you describe
it um actually I think we should have
you know I've got to go I'm sorry I told
you I warned you this is going to happen
I I
[Music]
can
uh that's a really obscure thing to say
there
um you know what I'm I'm sorry to do
this I can I can you guys can talk about
this for a minute I will have to go
mobile so to speak but I will not be
able to do that for another five minutes
so I can all right can I can rejoin you
talked about this for we can easily talk
about this for five more minutes all
right okay I'll I'll rejoin you okay
okay I I think it's interesting your
text here which is you know whatever
it's just I think we've really talked
about but it says create an intermediate
test it
is I think to me that's an easy way to
understand it I don't know about the
word intermediate so much but it's kind
of like an inner
test inner test
subtest
um I Wonder though because I hadn't
really thought about it this way but
like you know when we were discussing it
earlier I mean is there an argument to
be made that verification test with ins
you know inside of another test should
just have the behavior of test
checkpoint um verification test doesn't
return the result I know right so my my
next question is going to be you know
that that to me would make sense right
it's weird the test checkpoint that
doesn't return a result can't be used in
the same way the verification tests can
be used right so I mean that that to me
seems like a thing that we should make
consistent either way and then the
question becomes what is the utility of
this thing assuming that verification
test is already a way to kind of add an
intermediate test just by by positioning
not by naming what does it mean for test
checkpoint to return a
value because I think that that to me is
really the thing that is distinctive
about test checkpoint it's not that it's
an intermediate test per se though
that's clearly a requirement it's that
it's it's
not you know it's not returning the test
itself it's it's kind of yeah well it's
returning the value of the thing it's
kind of
a like test as side one thing to say is
that I mean right now if you use a
verification test inside another
verification test it won't be collected
by the outer verification test and this
is because otherwise it will be
impossible to test the testing
system um
and and so we have this const that is
supposed to be used inside uh and is
collecting messages so it is different
also in that sense
um that when you use verification test
inste another verification test it
doesn't have the same behavior of
emitting um um yeah this this
intermediate
test
um maybe one could say should do it but
then it would be impossible to T testing
system or at least we will need to have
another construct that is doing it maybe
internal but yeah just saying yeah super
real verification test
final right but I think they serve
different purposes still because uh test
checkpoint is really much more like
something like a so something that
records but test uh somehow suggests
that certain decision will be made based
on whether it's uh returning like uh
true or false essentially whether it
testes passes or test fails but in this
case what is being done is that certain
checks are being internally recorded in
the process of test execution and those
values affect the decision whether the
overall test passes or
not yeah so it's different yeah I wonder
wonder if one way to think about this
though is because it's really made me
think I
mean so right now we have the confirmed
family of functions that alter control
flow when something goes wrong but you
know we've talked about like at least in
the air handling working group this
notion of you know this structured
replacement for messages and if we end
up having I think there's like this this
this
big kind of set of like dual dual you
know operations that can be defined on
functions that alter control flow and
functions that don't alter control flow
but have similar signatures right so we
have confirm we have confirm by we have
confirm quiet we have confirmed matches
um hypothetically in the future we might
have functions that are like and I don't
know what the the the the the verb or
the the you know the analog of the word
confirm would be because I'm going to
use check but that's not the right word
but you could imagine something like
check by or maybe be log by or log quiet
or log uh you know log matches or
something that doesn't ever affect
control flow but it does as a side
effect emit some kind of message uh that
people can opt into listening
to and I wonder if like test checkpoint
is
some early analog or you know early
precursor to that kind of thing where it
it works specifically in within a test
yes but it's its General behavior is
that it's a non-control flow altering
way of putting out a message that
something did or did not
match
um yeah I guess it
is and I don't know I mean I would
wonder if like maybe you
know I it's question of like the utility
of like there there are things about
test checkpoint like the fact that it
has the similar options to verification
test that do make it useful and the fact
that it's actually a test object and
we've talked about you know gives you
timing information and things like that
about specific checkpoint
operations
um but it does make me wonder if if
maybe
it's I don't know there's a more General
thing here that we if if that General
thing existed would just be something
that the testing framework could
understand and kind of plug into like
essentially like maybe the testing
framework would effectively run
functions using this the with logging
idea well for what it's worth in like
back when I was constructing this in in
many ways precursor to this current
ideas uh in for hour link I had this
with logging essentially in exactly the
same way as Stephen suggested that and I
had test logging also pretty similarly I
was collecting this log within the final
test result object uh but I'm sorry
could you clarify are you saying you had
a function called test logging yeah I
had a function called test log and I had
a function okay and I had a function
which worked something like with test
log something very similar to what
Steven suggested today and I also had a
function called test fail that basically
was a kind of a limited control flow
that was turning from a test early I did
not have a test checkpoint but because I
had test log I essentially could
record things although I didn't use that
that if I wanted explicit places which
decide where the test pass or not I
inserted more verification tests inside
my bigger test that's how I structur
things so I hadic I don't think that
logging is something that should be
specific to desk and obviously test
should be able to record all kinds of
stuff including probably s STD out as I
was saying and logging in the futter if
we have a framework to deal with that
sure but but I don't think we should
have any any anything specific for
testing well I don't know uh in practice
it's very convenient to have something
like test fail which is very
declarative and I think we discussed it
a lot we deci not to include it in the
current incarnation of testing system
just because it's something that we
could add later but in terms of utility
I would say it's very useful because it
reads very nicely especially given that
many tests are naturally written in the
procal way not in a functional way if
you have a bunch of statements that
import something similar to what you
regard have in your example in such
cases having something like test fail
somewhere in the middle can be
very
useful so we didn't include it I believe
not because we feel we think it's
useless but because we think that it can
be built on top of what we are building
right
now whenever we finally decide to
include it
right but I mean yeah you can either
start inventing all kinds of test
related function to break control
through and log or use system gener
function and include but regard there is
only one and it's called test mail you
won't need anything
else well probably
um but not for logging and we were
speaking about logging specifically not
about not for logging but logging I just
wanted to mention that my way of
implementing that was exactly similar to
what right now basically if you want to
fail a test you can just do if something
then abort and that will make the test
fail
um uh yeah fine it's just that a single
statement was basically what I think if
I remember correctly what I had was test
fail was taking a single argument which
was basically a reason for failure just
a single string I think and that was
enough to give very good
Diagnostics
but as we discussed we could add it
later so that that's why I think we
didn't discuss it so far at length
because we it is clear that with what we
have right now just as you mentioned
since you can use a board it can be a
some Thin wrapper like a syntactic sugar
based on that but it's useful in terms
of
readability
yeah right I sorry I'm kind of looking
at other words but you guys you're
talking about test fail now right just
just a simple function that makes a test
fa yeah I always like that idea as a
super readable way and that would be one
of the failure you could have the
message in it and there' be a little
failure we failure modes failure mod for
like exactly you know fail because of
test fail let's try to put in order the
the the kind of functions that we we
think are
um you know more suitable what is the
best
name um at this
point yes I I I'm not objecting to T
fail but is not the scope of the meeting
no it's not right we kind of
up I
suest can I suggest we put log matches
in there though just as a emphasize that
perhaps a generic thing would be
log log matches as just just kind of
like a test log but it's more it's a
generic function that happens to be
understood by the testing
framework
okay hi again everybody did you figure
it
out uh we a little
bit you know I was thinking about okay
what new suggestions some names what
about you you we had test checkpoint you
you suggest test point what about test
check look what does it do tell me in
one sentence what it does tell me in one
sentence what it does I think the
sentence here
is I can't see what's on the screen
because that we lost the opportunity
create an intermediate test to determine
whether input evaluates true um to
expect it yeah sorry to expect it yeah
an intermediate
test then why don't you call it
intermediate
test it is a possible name on the list
uh we're
thinking what
else other words is it is it anything
else
because
um which I think is in
comprehensible which one was
incomprehensible subtest is
incomprehensible all right inner test so
this is create test has an intermediate
test inside
it all
right I mean it's look I don't think
it's
terrible it's sort of
comprehensible anything too clever is
going to be
incomprehensible no this is true um what
about what about inner test as opposed
to intermediate
test well I like the Intermediate
because it gives a sense of time and
flow which is part of what the story of
this
is I mean it's it's a pass through test
it's a test that is I mean it would be
nice to give the idea that this thing is
a just a wrapper you understand what I'm
saying not a thing that affects control
flow it's some kind of pass through test
it's some kind of
uh I think you had test wrapper but that
isn't I don't like that yeah but you
understand what I'm saying that it's a
that it's a test that you just go
straight through but it has a side
effect right which is yeah I don't know
test to
meet no test it's
weird no that's what but I think that
that's kind of what the checkpoint
phrase you go to checkpoint stamp stamp
your passport and go on and that's what
this thing the whole point of a
checkpoint is that it can stop
things if there was if if a
checkpoint didn't ever stop things it
wouldn't need to exist
well that's not true checkpoints exist
in eras or something if you in eras you
go to a checkpoint it just records that
you came through it's not fair enough
fair enough okay so look what does
checkpointing mean in
programming I admit that there it it
tends to mean that you you know record
something and go on checkpointing is a
rather than a thing where you can be
diverted
right yeah and I mean at least within I
don't know the world of computers I mean
when I hear the word checkpoint I mean I
do understand Todd what you're getting
at and
it but I hear it as like it's like
you're saving state so that you can
recover later if something goes wrong
yeah exactly exactly exactly which is
again a different
thought that's yet a different confusion
from the one that I was
having
um what about test check you you
mentioned test check test point they
kind of have the same without actually
using the word
checkpoint I don't mind intermediate
test I don't have a problem I think it's
I think it's ugly I think it's ugly and
I think it doesn't communicate that it
is a a pass through test effectively
Stan put something in the zoom chat test
Milestone h no way too
ponderous right it's kind of a ponderous
way to say test checkpoint I
think and and Milestone even less seems
to sound this is a muddy concept and
this is why we're having trouble with
its name it's several different
things you know what about test assert
but it's not in it's not what it's doing
it's a concept okay no no no to speak
cleanly like everyone that we that we
have been talking to uh both QA and
other people that have seen this thing
they say that this thing is great and
this is exactly what we it's certainly
useful it's useful Ricardo it's useful
no question it's useful he meant but I
think it's also conflating multiple it's
conflating multiple ideas it's
conflating this logging idea which is
useful and this idea that it is a okay
what is this thing again what is it
again you're creating a test that is the
overall test that is it's a a runtime
test this is some something it just swws
something into the test results Stephen
it's it SWS an intermediate comparison
between an you know into the test result
but it only does that if if okay no not
really I mean you need to imagine that
the whole testing system is event based
basically every test it'ss an event and
it's just a matter of collecting all
those events and so basically yeah the
the the outer test collects the inner
events and so on and then the report is
built on top of the events only um so
what this does is basically yeah it emit
an event with the result of the test
that gets collected by other system
laters
um
I mean hearing it described that way
though makes me feel something like you
know something with log or logging in
the name feels
more yes we
don't what about test
event no it's not what it is it's not
what it
is it is it is itself a test right right
right it's more like a pass through
test it's not like a standalone test
which is what a test object
is right I mean it's what about test
check in a sense it just no it's not
it's not checking anything well checking
anything it's just recording it's not
checking it checks there should be some
consequence of it checking it's just
knowing the result of this you know it's
just you know it's it's a I mean one one
thing I don't like test check is because
they're test and check their synonyms
first of all but other than that I think
there is something that is changing when
when when a when an intermediate test
fails the other test fails as well so
there is something that breaks later not
the G flow okay okay that's good point
that's a good point that's one of seven
different un you know we will eventually
break this function into its different
component parts right now it's one of
those sort of One Man Band seven
different
things and those are sometimes useful
they are often useful they but but
eventually we will realize oh my gosh we
need a version of this function that
just does loging oh my gosh we need a
version of this function that just
causes the overall test to fail and
doesn't throw crud in the
log I mean right now you
can regular control flow but
yeah I think intermediate test is the
least bad of our
Alternatives especially given what you
just
said I don't mind it it is after all the
term that I I don't mind intermediate
test it is after all exactly what
Ricardo wrote in the usage message for
test checkpoint well I know that's why I
also the usage message
said let's go with intermediate tests as
an experimental it's an experimental
thing anyway but let's go with
intermediate
test I think it's the least the least
bad so to
speak okay okay just to play Devil's
Advocate though since it sounds like
we're oh sorry have to go in in like one
minute so go and advocate for the devil
well I'm just wondering you mentioned I
we don't have the testing framework now
but if we do or sorry the logging
framework but hypothetically if we were
to have the logging framework do we
think that intermediate test might
eventually be replaced with some more
General logging candidate or do we think
that's the wrong way to think about
this no I think there's a separate
logging wrapper that we might use that
could log a test where you could wrap a
logging emission around a test for
example or inside a test and you know
the logging thing would do something
sensible with a test that might you know
just look at a piece of the association
that is the test you know transmission
so to speak
yeah yeah I mean the more I think about
it just I think having like a an event
log associated with tests would be very
useful since that's kind of what's
getting produced by this thing
anyway yeah I agree so I think
intermediate test as an experimental
thing is the right thing for
now okay and what are some of the other
names that follow from this there there
there was there was check points or
something as a as an accessor property
right well I guess that will become
intermediate tests and yeah intermediate
test only the flat recursive one is
which I mean we we also want the
recursive one is called Flat maybe do we
want the non-recursive one why don't we
just why don't we just have it always be
flat why would you
want um well I guess call it the look
you could have all intermediate tests or
um you know intermediate test list I
don't know
what or flatten I'm afraid I really have
to I'm
sorry but okay and
thanks okay see you
than
okay